même s'il est très économique et facile
à préparer le tofu reste un mal-aimé
chez certaines personnes même soucieuses
de l'environnement de leur santé comme
certains membres de notre équipe alors
voici un nouveau guide d'achat et de
cuisson pour aimer cette protéine
végétale
[Musique]
n'étant toujours pas convaincu de ses
qualités gustatives et ne reculant
devant aucun défi trois collègues
carnivores de l'épicerie participent à
un atelier découverte sur le tofu donc
un bloc de tofu comme ça ça nourrit
comme une personne à la maison ça va
nourrir moi ma femme mais de fille et
puis ça va vous faire lunch pour la plus
grande
c'est parti
Erwan kerfers se spécialise en cuisine
végétarienne chez Atelier et saveurs le
tofu c'est très versatile c'est parfait
pour s'amuser parce que c'est comme une
toile blanche sur laquelle on peut aller
peindre ajouter des épices absorber les
goûts etc et jouer avec la texture
fait réagir grimacer sourciller mais je
pense que la meilleure façon de
convaincre quelqu'un de manger du tofu
c'est de le cuisiner puis de montrer
toutes les possibilités voici tout ce
que tu peux découvrir tout ce que tu
peux goûter qui va être vraiment qui va
amener de la variété qui va venir de la
couleur qui va amener de la texture dans
ton assiette ça va l'air parfait
exactement
bon on va travailler des boulettes de
tofu un petit peu à l'italienne d'accord
on va acheter du persil frais du romarin
du parmesan qu'on va les râper pour
apporter un petit côté ou mamie de l'ail
on va ajouter du paprika fumé un peu de
cumin que vous sentirez pas mais votre
cerveau va comprendre on va les jouer
avec votre cerveau pour apporter comme
c'était de la viande bon on y met plein
d'amour
on cherche un bon
le tofu est fabriqué un peu à la manière
d'un fromage on extrait la protéine des
graines soya par trempage et broyage
puis on ajoute un coagulant on presse
ensuite pour un extraire l'eau jusqu'à
la consistance désirée la consistance du
stuff fut va varier en fonction du type
de coagulant qui est utilisé pour
fabriquer le tofu est-ce qui est pressé
et ce qui est pressé beaucoup ou juste
un peu tout ça va changer la fermeté du
tofu sa texture aussi et d'une marque à
l'autre c'est très variable c'est comme
s'il y avait une classification qui
variait d'un fabricant à l'autre il y a
de l'essai erreur là-dedans
ici quelques-uns avant de trouver ce
qu'on préfère j'avoue que oui première
chose à faire c'est peut-être de le
prendre dans nos mains puis de tenter
délicatement pour savoir à quoi on a
affaire parfois on a du tofu mou qui est
plus ferme que du ferme ou de l'extra
ferme et parfois on a aussi du tofu sur
lequel il y a rien indiqué donc ça on
comprend que c'est du tofu normal
régulier qu'on peut trancher qu'on peut
couper en mais on n'a pas la fermeté qui
est indiquée si vous voyez tofu soyeux
il s'agit d'un tofu plus homogène plus
moelleux qu'en offre également à
différents degrés de fermeté il sera
utile pour faire des smoothies ou mettre
dans une soupe asiatique par exemple
c'est une crémeux moelleux cela pour
offrir du tofu à un bébé par exemple
c'est parmi les premiers Tofus qu'on
offre un bébé il a ça c'est merveilleux
ça fond dans la bouche mais plus le tofu
est mou moins il contient une protéines
le tofu soyeux et simplement la boisson
de soya qui est coagulée c'est la teneur
en protéines la plus faible on retrouve
à peu près un 3 g de protéines par 100 g
un bloc d'extra ferme lui contient
environ 16 g de protéines par 100 g
la demande pour le tofu ne cesse de
croître les ventes augmentent chaque
année de 10 à 20% depuis plus de 5 ans
mais ça s'en vient de plus en plus connu
donc les gens habitent s'habitue après
la cuisiner avec aussi cette
augmentation de la demande a poussé une
des nombreuses entreprises québécoises
qui fabrique du tofu ce Yaris a
s'installer dans une nouvelle usine 5
fois plus grande ok c'est tout nouveau
là oui c'est tout nouveau
de 2 à 5 dollars le bloc de tofu demeure
un aliment protéiné très abordable mais
il n'échappera pas à l'augmentation du
coût des aliments
le prix de la fève de soya a beaucoup
augmenté depuis la pandémie puis avec
l'inflation en plus on parle de minimum
30% juste pour l'achat des fèves de
Soyaux biologiques donc c'est sûr que
éventuellement ça va affecter les prix
certains fournisseurs parugation de 70
%. le prix du soya est étroitement lié à
celui du maïs et du blé du côté de
l'Union des producteurs agricoles on
s'attend à des augmentations encore
supérieures avec la guerre en Ukraine
important producteur de céréales ça
reste quand même beaucoup plus
avantageux d'un point de vue monétaire
d'acheter du tofu qui a de la viande
parmi les nouveautés sur le marché les
Tofus aromatisés ou marinés une option
intéressante si vous êtes pressé mais
cette transformation a un coût il y a un
coût pour les ingrédients ajoutés et
pour le fait que ce soit prêt à manger
dans le cas du tofu magique de l'uni si
je lis les ingrédients je vois tofu
sirop d'érable levure alimentaire sauce
soyao tamari vinaigre de cidre
cuisine mais ça pourrait être Stéphanie
cuisine ça pourrait être Johan cuisine
et donc du coup le fait d'aller à une
haute température va caraméliser notre
tofu c'est une belle croûte tout autour
après avoir réalisé la recette de
polpette italienne ou deux fûts dans une
sauce Marina nos trois collègues vont
découvrir le tofu enship une crème de
cacao ou tofu soyeux à la banane et une
brunoise de tofu caramélisé servi dans
le beurre et le sirop d'érable vous
voulez carrément les charmer là
ils ont bien travaillé on va commencer
par les polpettes d'accord
une période de transition que tu as
besoin de vivre avant de plonger
une référence aussi
comme le fish and chips avec une bière
blonde du Québec caoutchouc un peu quand
même
dans un riz frit où on va y mettre des
cubes de tof par exemple voilà mais par
contre pour compléter la teneur en
bouche on l'a frotté avec de la fleur de
sel et de la poudre d'algues nori voilà
plus vous allez le faire mariner
plus le tofu va absorber c'est saveurs
là plus du coup en bouche il va avoir du
goût et ça va être surprenant on passe
au dessert
la texture
on a encore la texture de caoutchouc un
peu c'est encore ce qui me freine un peu
évidemment le caramel au beurre salé
est-ce que vous allez cuisiner davantage
d'être vu à la maison vous l'essayer
en cuisine déjà ça
ouais ça donne envie mission accompli la
boulette c'est certain que je le dis